Welcome back to my series,
exploring the various ways that
sounds change over time and languages.
I'd like to wrap up these videos
with the look at rules and laws.
When someone identifies a regular sound
change pattern in language or from
parent to daughter
languages across history,
that pattern is traditionally
called a sound. Long key.
Laws are named after their discovers
or popularizer like grims law laws may
involved Llanishen dissimilation or any
of the sound changed types mentioned in
previous videos.
So grims law defines a systematic
sound change in [inaudible] manic,
the parent of every Germanic language
from Icelandic to German to Gothic to
English. Part of grins law
involves d voicing of voice stops.
So the pro Indo European or root
Gwyn turned into Quinn woman,
the English cognitives Queen.
Yeah,
we can write that particular rule.
As waste stops become voiceless,
stops grims law and other sound
laws are built out of rules.
These rules are the conventional way that
historical linguists state how sounds
change in the language.
The basic formula is simple.
Give the sounds that change the
sounds that they change into and the
environments where that change
takes place. So in Portuguese,
the letter s is pronounced
between two valves,
like in the word cosmos.
Here's the rule notation that tells us
interval Kalik s it's pronounced zoo in
that environment,
and here is the rule that voiced
stops in pro Indo European turned into
voiceless stops in dramatic
regardless of environment,
the order in relationship of rules
is crucial for understanding their
significance in the development
of a language. For instance,
you can use your understanding of rules
to establish a relative chronology,
meaning that you can determine
which changes took place
earlier than others in a
languages history.
Let's imagine a simple human language.
We'll give it a cool name.
Like x x underwent two minors,
sound shifts in one shift and
became em before a label consonant.
This language has the labels,
P and F in other words,
and assimilates to a following Lavia
in the second shift, a short
unstressed, it was deleted,
but only if it occurred
between two consonants. In
other words, unstressed, Eh,
undergo syncopy.
NowX has a word aim fee.
Comparing data from
closely related languages.
Just as we did in the introduction
to historical linguistics,
we've been able to reconstruct the
pro form of that word as Unifi.
Now that I've given you this info,
tell me which sound change happened first,
deleting or changing and to m to
help you answer that question.
Let's build rules for
the two sound changes.
First end becomes em before a
consonant with the feature label.
Second unstressed,
it becomes nothing when
it's between two consonants.
If the Prodo word is yen,
if she then applying rule one first
leaves us with Oh fee since end doesn't
assimilate to a following consonant,
it comes before vow but then we'll
to applies leaving us with yen fee.
But language x has yin fee,
not yen fee.
So
Rach that try the reverse order rule two
turns Unifi into yen fee and now rule
one can apply. Leaving us with yen
fee, which is exactly what we find.
So it looks like rule to
took place before rural one,
which is our relative chronology.
This fictitious but credible example from
language x raises awareness about not
only the timeline of rules
but the order of those rules.
When an earlier rule creates
an environment in which
a later rule can operate.
The two rules are said to have a
relationship described as a feeding order.
There earlier rule feeds
into the second one.
So in language x rule number one which
deleted it allowed rule number two which
changed and to m to apply.
That's an example of a feeding direction.
When the rules are reversed,
the earlier rule abandoned and environment
which is filled by little later rule,
the result is a counter feeding order.
Let's imagine that early in its history,
our language x had a rule that
deleted em before a consonant,
any consonant whatsoever.
The parent language had a word lump fee,
but this first rule and becomes nothing
between a vowel and a consonant applied
to that Prodo word giving the output
left fee in language x a later rule.
The one we're already familiar
with changed end to em
before a label consonant.
So rule one deleted am's before consonant,
but rural to put them right back in,
not in the same words,
but it recreated the environment.
When an earlier rule creates
an environment in which a
later rule cannot operate
the two rules in a bleeding order.
The outcome, the first rule applies,
and the second one doesn't
go back to language x,
which has a rule that deletes m
after a vowel, but before a constant.
It was this rule that changed the
Prodo word lump fee. Two left feet.
Young speakers of x are
applying a new rule these days.
They Insert have pee in
the consonant cluster,
m f so instead of saying they say,
but they fail to apply rule number two
to laugh fee which lost its cluster MF
thanks to rule number one,
when the bleeding rules are reversed,
the earlier rule operates,
followed by the later role,
which would have prevented the
earlier rule from applying.
The result is a counter bleeding order.
The outcome here is different.
Both rules apply returned to our rule in
language x that deletes and unstressed,
Eh,
in the middle of a word.
But here's a new rule that moves
stress to the pen ultimate.
The second to last syllable of a word.
That first role helped turn
Jenny feet into Yemen fee,
but it also caused the
word off the SA to change,
to offset this new accent shift moves
the stress to the first syllable,
resulting in the modern word off.
So instead of off side had
a Fisa change to our Fisa,
it would have prevented the rule
that deletes that unstressed, eh,
but since it happens second, the two rules
apply in a counter bleeding direction.
This series has taken the time to
share types of sound changes with you,
as well as how to state those sound
changes using phonological rules.
I appreciate your interest and your
attention throughout the series,
and I thank you for taking
the time to learn with me.